Hey. Welcome.
Today, we're gonna take a look at how
my stream is automated and how easy it
is for me to schedule a new episode
of clustered.
Now you'll see there is no stream schedule
for this one for today and then one
next week, but there's no clustered on Thursday,
something that I normally schedule every Monday.
Oops. I'm a little bit late today, but
it has worked out in our favor.
Now
everything is German through a headless CMS. This
is the Contentful.com.
I'm on the free plan, which gives you
25,000
entries.
You'll see I'm only using 300,
But we're going to search for
clustered.
And here, we will see some of the
episodes that we've had recently.
The most recent episode was clustered 16.
But because this week's episode is a team's
edition, I am going to clone this.
Clustered is pretty much the same every week.
The guests change, but the description and
other
the description and other things are all the
same. But, really, I'm just going to come
in here and update the teams.
And spoiler alert, this Thursday's custard is feature
in teams from Digital Illusion and from Skyscanner.
From here, I can tell it which show,
so I can have different branding, descriptions, and
automation depending on the shows that I'm I'm
working on. Right now, it primarily is just
Rawkode Live.
We have a series which allows us to
have some pretty nice
description
or at least linkage within our videos.
So let me just make sure that doesn't
play. But if we jump down here and
say show more,
you'll see that the series actually lists every
other episode of clustered on the link.
So by adding
our episode to this, we will see
all previous episodes of clustered description be updated
to include
the new video.
And let me just show you what this
looks like. So we'll remove this just now
and we'll add that back in after we've
already published it so you can see that
cascading update across our videos.
This week's episode is, well, this week.
Why can't I scroll? I'm gonna move it
off monitor.
That's an interesting bug.
Okay. We've updated it to July 29. I
believe the time is 05:30
as always.
It is awesome. Nothing to change there. And
now we're gonna change our teams. So we
can hit move from this is I get
for trying to do it on my little
monitor so I can look straightforward the whole
time.
Now
we will add digital
ocean.
Thank you. And Skyscanner.
And insert.
And those are our two guests, two teams
for this episode.
I could scroll down here
and update this.
But, yeah, this is slightly repetition.
I could definitely automate this too, but for
now, it's alright.
Thank you to Teleport for continuing to sponsored
clustered.
We scroll down. Now we don't want to
use this image,
so we'll remove it. We don't want to
overwrite an existing YouTube video, so we'll remove
it.
And we have a JSON editor here that
just puts on the first time segment for
the video.
We have no length,
and now
we have published.
Now what's happening behind the scenes was that
Contentful is configured with a webhook configuration.
And you'll see that whenever I update a
series, an episode, or a guest, it triggers
a function on pipedream.net.
Pipe dream is then reaching out to YouTube,
but it's checking to see if that YouTube
ID exists. If it doesn't, it goes and
creates a video. And then checks to see
if an image exists. If it doesn't, it
generates an image. And then once it has
all of those missing components,
updates the description
and publishes the entire thing.
Now we're gonna do the CDs modification
shortly after, but first, let's go back to
Rawkode.live
and see if our new episode is listed.
And there it is.
Cluster teams, DigitalOcean, and Skyscanner.
Now this image is generated for us. It
pulls in their images from GitHub profile photos.
So this is the DigitalOcean logo from GitHub,
and this is the Skyscanner logo from GitHub.
Not the best example in this automation because
they're transparent, but still cool that it's all
done.
This is all generated for us from the
automation on Pipedream. So, you know, I didn't
say that this is Rawkode Live and it's
hosted by me and this is my website,
etcetera. I didn't set that we wanted a
timeline or the guest information and team information.
This is all part of that automation that
comes through for us.
You'll see there's no list here of clustered
episodes.
So we're gonna fix that now.
We jump into here and we'll see this
is
clustered.
I will hit publish.
What should happen now is that we should
be able to pop over
to the YouTube page, refresh the description,
see the series information
on our new DigitalOcean and Skyscanner video.
Not only that, I should be able to
click on any clustered video and see our
new episode.
In fact, it's already reloaded
page for me. That's nice. Let's just do
it anyway.
And we have our CDs information
and we have the order's a little bit
funny, but there we go. We have DigitalOcean
and Skyscanner here. Now I'm just going to
click on the very first episode of clustered
and pop down,
and we should see
our new episode.
So that's my stream automation.
Stay tuned
because I'll be live streaming, rebuilding all of
this automation using nothing but open source cloud
native technologies,
using Git as a source of truth for
all episodes, series, and guests.
Remember to subscribe. Remember to like this video.
Remember to jump onto the Discord at Rawkode.chat.
See you soon.